peu
[Musique]
la terre n'est dans l'univers qu'une
minuscule planète
[Musique]
elle tourne inlassablement autour du
soleil qui est lui une étoile et c'est
l'état d'y faire pipi
on va chercher ta soeur
c'est d'ailleurs l'étoile la plus
rapprochée de la terre 149 millions 600
mille kilos
la seule étoile qui peut vous sembler
reste fx est l'étoile polaire
[Musique]
à
il restait pas là les enfants et surtout
ne touchez pas au pupitre à aller et
pourtant elle plus lentement que les
autres mais au cours des siècles elle
bouge comparé dans sa position actuelle
à celle qu'il occupait en zéro de notre
ère maintenant transportons nous dans
l'avenir
voici la position peu cupra l'étoile
polaire en l'an 3000
c'est la preuve en astronomie même ce
qui paraît immuable n'est pas star le
soleil et les étoiles comme sirius par
exemple font partie d'une galaxie qu'on
appelle la voie lactée la voie lactée
d'ailleurs n'est pas la seule galaxie
qui existe est ce que vous croyez qu'il
ya des gens qui peuvent habiter sur les
étoiles sur celle là celle qui brille
mais personne ne peut habiter dans le
feu vous avez dessus cette petite tâche
que vous apercevez là est andromède 400
milliards des toiles limpide je voudrais
et là haut sur cette étoile
j'ai sur quelqu'un
je vais sur une étoile ne sera peut-être
pas encore mais tu serais déjà mort 38
puisque ça c'est sûr une étoile regarde
comme tout briller les étoiles ou les
galaxies qu'on aperçoit à l'oeil nu ou à
travers un télescope ne sont pas très
éloignés de nous il y à d'autres
montrent que nous ne pouvons pas voir et
dont la présence nous est révélée par
les ondes sonores
[Musique]
monsieur sirius 5 quelle distance des
chiffres pour voir les 1000 km tu es
loin du compte
sirius figure toi et à 85 mille
milliards de kilomètres
nous sommes seulement au début de
l'investigation des espaces infinis qui
sait quelles découvertes nous ifo quels
bouleversements vont subir nos
conceptions plus que jamais notre avenir
est dans les étoiles
[Musique]
jyg des tueries et maman qui nous attend
maman est chez le coiffeur vraiment être
très content qu'ils ont c'est père n'a
pas du tout envie d'aller voyager dans
l'espace
la bidc à faire avec le choix de ses
robes et c'est très bien comme ça qu'est
ce que c'est
qu'est ce qu'il ya derrière est-ce que
c'est comme une fête qui sera puis
est-ce que c'est comme ma mère folha
mail il ya du sable au fond du ciel
berckois et que tout footballeur
j'écoute pas quand je regarde j'écoute
après alors je me souviens aujourd'hui
j'ai tout lu tu verras
[Musique]
pas de route entre 4 la normale
[Applaudissements]
au contraire peut-être rien de
particulier en comparant le nombre
important week end a été complet vite
vite philippe une étoile filante
c'est mon étoile elle me cherches tu as
fais moi tu dit de bloc vaut rien c'est
qu'elle n'était pas pour toi
il m'a fait signe elle m'a dit c'est toi
c'est vie j'écrivais oui oui oui
par tanguy taille et rien du tout et
puis l'école à 10 par me sylvie tu as
des visions on peut dire que votre
visite au planétarium est un événement
ne parlait plus que de commettre des
poils allé all-in
ouais je vois rien du tout tu vas jamais
rompu les filles vous croyez toujours
les plus mal il ne s'était pas vraiment
de vous disputer filet couche toi ou
j'appelle ton père
pourquoi je reviens avec nous
l'intérieur jeu télé déjà dit j'avais
toutes sortes de courses urgentes
je regrette bien mes chéris de ne pas
avoir vu toutes ces belles choses avec
nous maintenant il faut dormir toujours
quoi il se passe des choses
intéressantes qui trop dormir mais la
nuit ne se passe rien
dit que là vraiment vu jeter toile oui
je crois coué
toutes ces étoiles sont classés par
constellation qui portent des noms
grecque soulève le sagittaire aurions
les pléiades hercules cassiopée et cd
rom elles sont si loin que leur lumière
nous parvient des années après
c'est pourquoi on ne compte de leur
éloignement quand années lumière non
monsieur c'est pas vrai on compte aussi
un kilomètre voyez vous ça et qu'est ce
qui t'a rendu 6 à vendre des journaux
la télévision peut être je suis allé au
planétarium selon monsieur vous y êtes
déjà allés non mais ça ne change rien
moi j'ai vu où sera l'étoile polaire on
en prend 1000 du mouvement des planètes
autour du soleil
tu vu mais maintenant tu vas aller voir
dehors si les étoiles sont levés allez
ouste
finances
[Musique]
sinon je disais donc que ces étoiles
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
vieux monsieur
est ce que tu t'es fait mal moi non je
trouvais ça tue pas vous non et qu'est
ce que c'est je suis pas à l'intérieur
tu as des choses qui firent au mur qu'il
en dise non non c'est pas moi
[Applaudissements]
qui
fille qu'est ce que tu fais rien c'est
pas vrai tu fais pas rien et pas
question du fait non comment ça s'était
rentrée citant des lycées et voici
comment ça se fait que m'embête pas
opter passé comme théâtre est jetée pas
vu je suis passé par la lune tu passais
par sérieuse par la pléiade par
cassiopée je joue avec mon embauche ou à
la peur et tu te donnes quelque chose tu
t'en tenir à ce débat oui si tu veux bon
alors fermés yeux
elle te plaît mais voilà il va jouer en
haut tu l'as trouvé où on l'a donnée si
ça te regarde pas maintenant film a
promis de partir j'avais bien promis
menteuse tu payeras tu as oublié ce que
je t'ai dit mon tout jeune on ma
portière camp
oh
votre papa il est dans son bureau
j'ai mis tout à fait au point de cheveux
coupés alors les réseaux votre nouvelle
idée attendez vous et regardez moi ça
hein qu'est ce que vous en dites
un snack-bar 2000 même ça c'est une idée
pour moteurs et vous le voulez en coin
en bois moulé en panne pour ce groupe g
du ru non je veux de la pierre de la
vraie pierre avec du bois du vrai bois
un bar en vrac à jour avec fauteuils
club banque est tout ce qu on ne
s'attend pas à trouver davantage quoi
que demandent les clients du confort du
rêve
alors on fait un devis monsieur dur et
je lui mets tout de suite bien donnez
moi un tour de faveur parce que je ne
pense plus qu'à se ce n'est pas ce night
2000 je raccompagne oui
papa je prépare les non j'ai pas le
temps je reconduis monsieur douillet on
voit tu n'as pas la sienne
il
je cherche partout allez la toile m
non non il sera philippe c'est que la
chance d'habiter toute l'année à la
montagne gilbert tu peux faire du ski il
était monté à cheval ou jouer au tennis
et tout le temps respirait le bonheur
tandis que nous pauvres citadins qui
vont dans la fumée des autres mobiles et
non piscine se sont rempli d'une eau qui
sent le corps c'est ce que tu apprécies
tout ça en tout cas tu en profites moi
je prends l'avion ce soir à l'effet
alors un lissage d'akoupé bas le fait
pas tout ce que je veux lui donnant une
fessée de la part au soir mais j'ai ri
tout va bien tout ce personnel malade je
suis débordée qu'est ce qu'on mange et
du beauf roi la famille sinon c'est très
bon pour la santé mondiale du fer je
reviens
comptez 2
[Musique]
hop on avait de l'appétit ce soir nous
avons reçu un excellent poisson avec une
sauce hollandaise gay c'est tellement
bon c'est plus qu'un moment d'ouvrir
deux bien madame o duffau fois dû au
froid pour l'emploi 22 vit dans un hôtel
comment elle s'appelle ta poupée
j'ai pas encore on cherche tous les deux
dis moi tu les aimes toi les épinards
vous avez une nouvelle poupée elle
s'appelle comment déjà
ah oui l appât menton puis elle a l'air
rudement méchante méchant pas du tout
c'est toi tu es méchante m'appeler mario
de lui la main avec le travail que je
j'ai encore le temps de dire bonjour
occupés alors à l'ambitieux des balles
enfant je passais brühlmann au soir j'ai
été renversé mais c'était pas encore là
instant de répit
il paraît que ce vincent le bouchon
qu'en penses tu les gens me demandaient
pourquoi de derrière les fagots et comme
une preuve de la bibine doute avaient
ils s'imaginent plus le vin qu'on leur
sert est bouchonné nouveau notre
bouteille marrant celles ci ont tout
vérifié soi même un très bon soir parce
que nous tous
il est guéri tu vois j'ai les bras
internet d enlever je ne peux pas
quitter vous chic
ap dîner j'ai bien tapé les jambes je
vais dire dis bonjour à la poupée si
bratton eelv aura fait intel
vous n'avez pas encore dean et moi je
vois des pluies se pressent pour la
jolie poupée quitte la donne et c'est
fini eh bien ces rues de montgeon
tous l'espèrent
du coup lyon
oui
cette fois ci les fameux je vois vous
êtes un connaisseur vous prendrez vous
ce soir je vous conseille un peu vengé
donc donnerez des nouvelles
non ici on veut manger de la fondue pas
vraiment bien sûr une veyron du sablar
quand mes fils ont joué toute la journée
ils avaient leur est tout ce qu'il ya
dans votre cuisine
oui une énorme fondu avec du vin du jura
le bourgogne c'est par là directif puis
vous tombez congelés et puis une grosse
tarte aux abricots binaire s'éteindre
philippe pour tuer trouver ces poupées
je t'ai déjà dit que ça ne regardait pas
dépêchez vous les enfants tu peux bien
vous dire c'est un copain qu'une admis
un garçon qui auraient loupé c'est pas
possible
bon idiote à l'état sa soeur moi j'ai
fait un pari et j'ai gagné
drôle de copains qu est ce que tu le
connais pas
[Musique]
qu'est ce que tu fais rien je garde quoi
j'ai pas je comprends pas c'est fini les
enfants n'oubliez pas de perros et
reviennent même terreau à jojo avec la
malade depuis une éternité
mon mari ça n'était mais à cette heure
ci nous sommes submergés
vous savez le jeu et partir sans payer
dès que le taxi sera là je suis
conseiller gentil fait descendre vos
bagages et dans deux secondes vous aurez
votre note que vous le promets merci je
veux je l'aurais dit nous nous le montre
tu ne mangeras pas de talent quand tu
auras beau bois ton petit coeur qui
devra soigner sa mère nous ne te
retourne pas c'est très bien mais je me
retournais pages on a toujours la même
chose au fait tu t'amuses avec nous
regardent comme c'est joli toutes ces
petites lumières
qu'est ce que tu veux savoir où tu l'as
trouvé qui fait mal a daigné honorer que
voilà cinq ans
secret et ce qu'ils feront tout seul
mais après j'en savais plus quoi faire
et toi si tu avais peur cheveux pierre
clermont andreu vous avez vient n'est
pas bruyant ça je dois dire que le dot
entière et 10 passes un fils il
travaille déjà très bien à l'école quant
à sylvie malgré son jeune âge elle écrit
elle lit déjà très correctement
est ce que notre repas ou cordelle tout
à fait je ne suis jamais très justement
ce que je mange
notre cuisine ne vous plaît pas si mais
je pense à autre chose
tous ces gens réunis dans cette salle
quelle existence différents quelle
passion il n'imagine a atteint de
vertige
j'attends ma petite amie viens t'asseoir
pour être moi la tient rennes poupée que
ne connaissez pas encore hélas curieux
10la geoffron mantoue pointu c'est un
nouvel enfant est ce que tu lui
racontent de belles histoires pour
l'endormir
je ne connais pas d'histoire vous en
livrons ressemble bon létard
tu vas dire bonsoir avec moi c'est le
genre du bon et surtout ne pas permis
chez jaguar
tu voulais me louer un tout petit
coquinou roma noizet jamais de mcafee
pour tenter vous elle voudrait jamais
est-ce que je peux les regarder quelle
drôle de costumes oranges comme c'est
bizarre
paul regarde sa voix qu'elle peut pas
démontable
mais mais mais les paiements sont garés
vous avez vu à temps excusez moi
attention maman après un grand pas il ne
faut pas d'émotions mais je n'ai jamais
vu ça mais elle n'a pas de coeur
et si elle en accueille comme tout le
monde il est à droite si je n'ai pas la
berlue
on va voir celle du pas mort mais c'est
une horreur
on devrait interdire de telles jouer
viage ici tu as sommeil bien allons nous
en vous aussi venez et qu'est ce qui se
passe qu'est ce qui t'arrive servi mais
n'ont rien de grave il n'y a pas de quoi
fouetter un chat pour clients sont bien
nerveux
c'est tout simplement une poupée
démontable on n'a pas idée de
confectionner des objets paraît regardez
le coeur les poumons
voilà ces scandales et qui est plus
inventé ça vous est ce que ça peut bien
sortir cv qui t'a donné ce monstre moi
tu trouvé cette machine dans ses
magasins un statut répond à la fin je
reviens que lyon ne peut pas n'importe
quoi aux enfants
calme-toi je t'en prie le docteur a
seulement voulu amusé sylvie toi ma
petite fille
il est temps de monter dormir dit
bonsoir mademoiselle jean dubos il ne
faut pas avoir peur s'il vit cette
poupée ne peux pas te faire du mal du
reste personne ne peut faire de mal à
une petite fille comme toi aller voilà
voilà comment on fausse esprits des
enfants des jouets anatomique du chemin
culturel d'accord à condition que tous
sont parfaitement exact pourquoi dû
accepter ce qui est aussi docteur nerfs
dans sa valise lors il me l'a donnée on
les fidèles et vite
[Musique]
plus
une
où
s'enfermant avec plaisir dans leur
obscurité et partageant avec les
malheureux le pain noir qu'ils payent de
leur sang point final
c'est alfred de vigny vous allez vous
relire corriger vos portes et souligner
tous les compléments circonstanciels et
faire l'analyse logique indiqué bien
tout les subordination vous avez juste
un quart d'heure et papili tasse de thé
appliquée sinon ça ira mal
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
ce que je retiens
il dit avant de regarder devant nous
notamment sur l'antenne comme ça
alors qu issu du mois
où étais-tu passé je t'avais pourtant
interdit de aux petits monstres
nous voulons faire mourir de chagrin
[Musique]
le
qu'est ce que c'est au kenya nouveaux
trucs comme ans auxerre o tu met à mal à
plusieurs gars qu'est ce qu'on y voit un
sifflet c'était dans leurs pensées de
tout poil garçons surtout moins qu'en
plus tu m'as tu en voilà
[Musique]
qui se tarir idiote c'est moitié verizon
hiffler alors tu vois je vois rien c'est
pas possible c'est si joli
[Musique]
oh
go
[Musique]
regardez tous les deux en même temps
m
[Musique]
et
on
[Musique]
tiens pour toi alors qu'est-ce que dans
les bars ya rien à voir
tandis que moi
[Musique]
où
il fera jamais je sais pas moi peut-être
qu'un jour les images qu'on épuise i
puis peut-être qu'il y aura toujours de
nouvelles parties soit au lycée est ce
que je pourrais regarder en ont bien moi
l'eee pad ou deux tu crois que je chie
parce qu'il ya un pas dans la lèche les
bottes encore et quelle fougue partir où
ça là bas non même si les images
comment veux tu qu'on rentre dans un si
petit cube maggi pas me chercher
tellement de choses en bas dans ton
placard que tu crois qu'on croit s'en
servir tu crois peut voir les quais
[Musique]
et
on
[Musique]
oh
ans
e
[Musique]
mademoiselle après plaisir de me voir
oui un thème une histoire bien faire
elle veut pas me parler
je vais te dire comment tu peux parler
avec elle tu poses une question et tu
mets ton oreille sur son coeur deux
coups ça veut dire oui trois coups non
elle reste toujours toujours toutes les
poupées sont faites pour ça que
j'essaierai je vais vous montrer quelque
chose
c'est trop tard vous mais ça même si ma
main est trop grande et toi dis moi ce
que tu as vu il pleut beaucoup de fleurs
mais aussi une étoile je courais prier
elle veut pas si ces preuves alors je me
heurtais michel eu une drôle de petite
bonne femme je t'aime beaucoup tu sais
je me revois petite fille à ton âge ça
t'amuse de penser que j'étais une petite
fille comme toi
connais-tu les aventures d'alice au pays
des merveilles
je suis sûr qu'elle te plaire ou de me
dire acheter libye a coûté mais tout de
suite commencé comme un âge où alice -
lapin blanc tirait une montre de son
gilet y regarder l'heure il est en
retard il regagne son terrier entre
temps alice se fait tout petit et et
l'autre derrière lui dans le terrier
bakou elle tombe dans le vide pendant
des jours et des jours elle va continuer
à tomber elle suffisamment et les deux
minuscules quand elle sort de la sat et
allons allons elle touche les murs
ce que j'aimerais tri elle te ressent et
quand tu connaîtras ses aventures tu lui
ressemble encore plus n'oublie pas
d'interroger ta poupée elle c'est pas
mal de choses qui te seront utiles pour
faire quoi pour faire comme alice aller
au pays des merveilles
traverser les miroirs je vais avez loupé
joyeux c'est norte plaît
elhadji oui je commençais à m'ennuyer
maintenant je l'appelle alice et en
amuse beaucoup
et puis mademoiselle aujourd'hui baum a
appris un truc pour la faire parler tu
lui poser une question d'écouter son
coeur du coup pour wii trois coupes pour
long et ça donne quoi
tout ce que tu veux savoir est ce qu'on
prend bientôt en voyage
après vierge
et tu as déjà demandé des choses des tas
de choses je marie si j'étais enfant des
chiens des bijoux elle m'a dit aussi que
je partirai et où ça ouais mais tu
m'emmènera je ne partirai jamais sans
toi oui mais on ne ratera pas il y à des
endroits où on ne peut pas nous
rattraper ou du les a vus dans le cube
qui sait bien
enfin une pénalisation pas l'épée à sa
compagne également
accès de fièvre sur le marché de l'or
est fière de marché passée
10 millions à 1 milliard dans ses
lingots a encore monté et surtout la
partie atteinte puis exactement charest
système qui n'est plus un enfant lormont
je te l'avais prédit avant plutôt des
enfants je leur trouve un air bizarre tu
n'as rien remarqué monsieur terrazzo
c'est urgent
par les wikis at il abusé madame le
docteur nerfs voudrais vous parler est
bien branché téléphone il est à bout des
doigts malades a dit ici
bon je descends tu me donnes tu es donc
tout à fait surprise déjà aura tout à
vous je vous pouvez pas vous passer de
nous la date du congrès a été différée
je me suis dit profitant encore de la
neige et du soleil
revenons chez nos amis des oiseaux voilà
une bonne lancée
a propos je ne faisais pas encore
remercier vous avez gâté sylvie je ne
vois pas bien ce que vous voulez dire
mais si cette poupée 7b si original
démontable et quand vous avez remis la
fille qui peut l'être à sylvie non
vraiment je ne vois pas jamais je ne me
rappelle pas monsieur reprenez-vous il
me coupe est bien entendu d'obtenir
votre chambre fait monter les balises
vidéo prénataux 17 non je vous en prie
je connais chemin
il n'y avait qu'à voir sa tête n'est pas
le docteur énerve qui a donné cette
poupée
quand j'étais sûr jamais ils n'auraient
faire apparemment ceux qui exagèrent que
le coeur soit à droite ou à gauche
quelle importance pourvu qu'il y en est
un après tout c'est une poupée comme les
autres as tu trouve toi je veux dire la
chose au clair et tout de suite oui ton
frère
qu'est ce que tu dis merci voilà qui est
ce qui peut traverser un miroir un
encore une bêtise mais pourtant défendu
quand on donne des histoires à dormir
debout à mes enfants mais c'est très
amusant les aventures d'alice
il vit quitte à donner ses livres
mademoiselle gens d'ubs ont maintenant
une femme qui a des visions et qui étire
l'horoscope des femmes de chambre
je ne peux pas m'occuper de tout ce qui
se passe dans cet hôtel je les ai déjà
dit je ne veux pas que les enfants
acceptent n'importe quoi des clients
c'est à toi qui es tu y crois j'ai le
temps s'est vu où se cache ton frère ce
pas dismoioù écrivait samba dans la
lingerie
car il ya des tas de choses ça doit être
comme apte pour le service doit ses plus
vastes et là je t'en prie le crie pas
sur tous restent calmes
[Musique]
je veux tu on cherche partout je m'amuse
quel est ce nouveau jeu je sais pas
c'est un truc bizarre il faut mettre les
pères là où c'est nécessaire de le dire
qui tu as ta musique aussi pareil
il était de faire des mensonges le
savons tous les deux perdent nerfs des
revenus as tu décidé à me dire la vérité
tu vas recevoir récupérera guitariste du
brand injures pas mis moi tous viennent
ces choses
le moteur vous voyons fini on ne trouve
pas le pari objets dans la neige était
dans une voiture volée quelques uns les
ouvriers burqa naturiades et je voudrais
me ont vécu par la vie peut durer
peut-être c'est pas une raison pour
cacher dans une armoire des jouets qui
ne sont pas à toi les enfants vous avez
remonter dans votre chambre
je sais ce que j'ai décidé la punition
de filet et pour commencer je confie ce
que les jouets et toi inutile de
m'attendrir avec des larmes du poker ça
ne croit pas en paix pour une fois les
enfants voulaient s'amuser paisiblement
qu'il est arabe et je trouve est annoncé
je secret silencieux peut-être même un
peu scientifique
moi je les trouve monstrueux et stupide
tant que banquier touchant aujourd'hui
je ne tiens pas se concrétise les
enfants d'ailleurs je vais demander au
dr nerfs des examens et les enfants tu
es fou c'est un psychiatre
je suis fou mais gagnera aussi voilà je
veux savoir si les cerveaux de mes
enfants fonctionne normalement comme tu
veux mais je trouve ça tout à fait
inutile et même
oui je mets grand que ramasser cette
grande boîte dans la neige mais sûr
qu'il n'y avait personne dans sa note a
vu l'entente est non partant alors je te
dis je peux l'apprendre ce n'est à
personne donc c'est à moi mais j'ai eu
l'impression de faire quelque chose
demain un peu mal ou de raison chez moi
entre demain et briques a donné la
poupée a suivi difficiles et quand on
vous a demandé d'où venaient ces drôles
de jouer vous avez répondu c'est le
docteur vénère les années mais je suis
revenu je ne voudrais pas vous avez
menti mais vous ne pourriez pas faire
autrement
oubliez garder c'est vrai qu'on vous
parce que vous les aimez beaucoup mais
vous aimez aussi vous parle et ses
jouets ne plaisent pas ce papa ni à
votre maman
cela vous inquiète le secteur parce
qu'ils comprennent
oui non se sont servis
dangereux a par exemple celui
d'affronter mon appel
[Rires]
curieux je crois que je comprends au
fond c'est le hasard
c'est comme un kaléidoscope qui mélange
tout ah non pascal et de scop c'est le
hasard
tandis que là sylvie peut faire
disparaître la perle exactement où elles
vont montrez-lui sylvie elle va
disparaître ici
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à y bien
mais vous ne m'avez pas encore répondu
vous aimez vos parents oui normalement
j'aimerais vous demander quelque chose
quand vous jouez avec ce réseau avec ce
cube avec cette poupée
j'aimerais que ce ne soit pas en
cachette
j'ai obtenu de vos parents qui ont boudé
laisse vous avez l'autorisation de jouer
mais nous on a besoin que ce soit en
cachette
pourquoi parce que ça marche mieux il
faut qu'on soit tous seuls pour regarder
la poupée il faut personne le sache où
on n'a pas ce qu'on fait que ça parle ça
parle mais qui par delà les autres ceux
qui ne sont pas ici ils veulent me dire
des choses mais vous sentiez mais c'est
possible
c'est bien possible
c'est rudement intéressant et bien je
crois que c'est l'heure de ma petite
promenade vous voulez venir les qua non
à l'or a toutes les raisons de nous ici
tous les jouets monsieur à total
ton papa n'a pas l'air très content
cheese de conte de fées a dit ce n'est
pas un conte de fées qui est une
histoire pleine de raison où en
étions-nous ici sifflement strident de
la locomotive
tout le monde fuit d'un bond de terreur
dans le wagon alice comme les autres un
cheval qui avait passé la tête à la
portière la retire a tranquillement et
dit ce n'est rien cet or huit sauts que
nous allons sauter tout le monde
paraissait satisfait mais alice était
inquiète à l'idée que le train pouvait
sauter une usine croyez qu'on peut
toucher le ciel en avion est sûr
mais on s'en aperçoit pas tout se passe
comme dans les rêves je n'aurais jamais
grève bien sûr la poupée rêve aussi
demande à alice je ne voyage pas quand
elle rêve
bonjour le terrain oui c'est un nouveau
gadget très utile dans mon métier on
peut laisser d ordre personnel et partir
tranquille mon snack la prochaine fois
vous viendrez il sera construit à 2000
mètres excellente idée le haut toujours
plus haut toujours plus de lumière assez
évocateur j'ai examiné les jouets j'ai
interrogé les enfants ne se porte à
merveille
physiquement c'est leur psychisme qui
posent pas mal de petits problèmes et si
l'on essayé de nous mentir c'est notre
métier de détecter les mensonges ce
qu'on fait aux autres est ce qu'on se
fait à soi même n'est pas normal que mes
enfants mentent à tous quoi philippe a
menti à sa soeur à vous et à moi au
sujet de cette prime il avait besoin de
matière comme tous les enfants j'aurais
jeté au fond dès le premier soir si
malick kamara docteur ces objets n'ont
aucun sens aucun sens pauvres ils sont
pleins de sens pour les enfants
voulaient pas dire que ce cube de verre
ce machin avec des billes c'est là
qu'intervient l'imagination et
justifient tous les mensonges et si les
gosses font des idées fausses faux selon
l'omb aléatoire les branchements une
poupée avec le caravan n'avait pas
prétendre que c'est la réalité
on peut concevoir l'espèce évolué
d'une autre planète qui aurait le faire
à droite et les viscères disposer
autrement que nous l'aurions chez nous
ne sommes plus très sûr de ce que vous
appelez la réalité pour doubler je ne
vais rien dire cher monsieur je constate
les enfants et les adultes deux agenais
sont celles capables de concevoir la
pluralité des mondes des possibilités
infinies de la matière aux enfants
voyez-vous cherche une piste à travers
le cube et la structure ou disparaissent
des listes braille ou si je le savais je
pourrais dire et je déçu jouer la poule
n auront pas vous avez fait recette des
gars comme cela géré par la situation le
revendre est maintenant sous hommes
car nous arrivons aux poèmes des mots
inventer des mots valises que la salle
des nouvelles
des mots dans lesquels on fourre tout ce
qu'on veut oh ben sedrine pratique
servent à dire deux ou trois choses à la
fois et ils font gagner du temps et
coûte bien il est aigri l'heure les
sleecs tutor j'irai sur l'albert et
gardy tout y est tous fliqués et télé
borgo et les corchia blues riboul fauqué
comme si joli film va en faire une tête
quand je lui parlais comme annie ne veux
pas savoir ce qu'ils veulent dire ces
mots
alice est plus curieuse que toi elle va
trouver le gros coco et lui demande des
explications grill heure par exemple
c'est l'heure de griller le pain pour
les parties les temps ce sont des
lézards qui ressemble aussi à des
tire-bouchons est de fait très joli os
en tout cas ils sont très drôles et
libéraux gauche libre go ce sont des
oiseaux minable comme de vieux petit
ballet qui vendraient g10 et pendant
tout de suite to speak était libre au
corps et les corses un blues auraient
voulu fauqué écoute il vit tu ne
t'attendais de rien tout peut arriver
tout est possible
non non c'est impossible ils n'ont
jamais été malades
sauf une seule fois quand ils ont eu la
rougeole tous les deux leur corps est en
parfaite santé
c'est leur imagination et qu'il est
poursuivi par la curiosité la curiosité
des forces obscures avez vous déjà
entendu parler des autres mondes
j'ai l'impression que vos enfants
cherchent d'entrer en contact avec les
forces d'un de ses modelages voyez-vous
les enfants et une logique qui l'aurai
toute personnelle cela ne veut pas dire
qu'ils raisonnent mieux que nous mais
qu'il raisonne autrement ils sont
différents
ces enfants que j'ai mis au monde je
sais comment ils sont est ils ont le
même coeur le même cerveau que moi non
plus tard peut-être ils vous ressemblent
rond mais aujourd'hui non seulement ils
sont différents d'hommes mais encore il
ne vous appartiennent pas vous êtes en
train de m'expliquer quel sont bizarres
et sont dans un autre monde
enfin dr je vous dis seulement que
l'esprit des enfants réagi autrement que
celui des adultes
il essaie de comprendre avec les
lumières qui possède mais dites moi
docteur selon vous par exemple que
diable peuvent-ils voir dans la
disparition de ces boules je ne le sais
pas encore avec certitude sans doute
déjà long sur une piste ils la
connaissent peut être déjà depuis
combien de temps manipule t-il ces
objets ou trois ou quatre semaines
oui oui c'est depuis en visite au
planétarium pour bien savoir d'où ils
proviennent
selon moi ce sont des objets fabriqués
pour faire passer des tests vous avez
remarqué les faisceaux lumineux de la
poupée non moi non plus mais les enfants
les droits
ils sont peut-être sensibles à des
rayons ou sensibilisées par quoi par
pied j'aimerais parler à vos enfants le
plus tôt possible
je pense qu'il faut aller très vite
excusez moi docteur nerfs vous avez une
communication de zurich vous permettez
j'arrive
excusez moi je respire c'est hurluberlus
mme qui est une peur et pourtant s'il y
avait quelque chose qui n'avait pas
souhaité écoutent ils se portent comme
des chats il nous ressemble
c'est ce docteur qui ne va pas bien je
vais leur expliquer le serment un peu
dérangée qu'il faut répondre à ces
questions par politesse mais les tenir
aucun compte de ce qu'il dira et son
histoire de test puis crois toi on ne
s'amuse pas à perdre des instruments
scientifiques dans la montagne c'est
invraisemblable ah oui mais alors d'où
viennent du ciel peut-être
je crois au volant mais l'ajustement de
gros ce week-end à rennes t'en fais pas
jusqu'à + mersen a bon l'air à la mouche
qu'est ce qui me touche
vêtu de figues dattes dans l'endroit est
que tournis schaller bulli boulud ou la
fiba nous tous les pouces tu me proche
très bien voire pas pour toi
ouais mais l'autre jour ils voulaient
bien l'autre jour si oui maintenant
c'est le vélo c'est jamais s'est jamais
non aujourd'hui c'était hier et demain
c'est toujours tu piges
schaeffer
tu es ce que tu m'avais promis de petits
monstres devenons faire mourir de
chagrin alors film mais il faut lui
t'oublie de lui using merci est sûre
quand j'écris ces mots tu tombes
bottines tu me trompe jamais après alice
moi je dis que c'est arrivé je me trompe
jamais la preuve
tavaux maison bis terrine en but sur
corner rami le début n'a pas suffi
philippe d'une apparente à ton âge ou à
coiffer les mots pareils c'est à devenir
fou
philippe toi qui est le plus grand des
exemples
proba et dit qu'elle a raison même quand
il a tort j'ai toujours raison
allez va prendre télé sont moins tu as
est joué
[Applaudissements]
tous vivent bien
docteur docteur les enfants de 10 et
incompréhensible il se dispute à propos
de je ne sais quoi
on dirait qu'il parle je ne sais pas
comment expliquer à côté du monde au
début je ne voulais pas vous croire
mais maintenant je suis inquiet très
inquiet rassurez-vous chère madame je
suis descendu les voir tout à l'heure
j'observe tout compenser bien que
j'interviendrai si je voyais quelque
chose d'anormal
les enfants sont sur une piste
ils vont trouver ce qu'ils cherchent
mais ces niveaux si caillou c'est comme
impensable
au début tout est confusion et petit à
petit chaque fragment reprend sa place
ce sont surtout ces mots sans queue ni
tête qui maintient ses mots ont un sens
pour eux il ne signification et sait les
faire des enfants ne font rien sans
raison il sortira quelque chose d'utile
et de bons de tous leurs efforts croyez
vraiment eh oui soyez sans crainte
savez vous mademoiselle que vous pouvez
m'aider beaucoup tant que cela oui vous
c'est lui est sûrement plus en confiance
avec vous lui lisais alice au pays des
merveilles
elle vous compte mille histoires vous
voulez que je travaillais ses petits
secrets je sais que vous ne le ferez pas
vous êtes complice mais vous pouvez
m'éclairer un peu que voulez-vous boire
une orange pressée et moi un collègue
sylvie est une enfant très doux et
imaginative très intelligente aussi et
dont la curiosité d'esprit est aussi
forte que l'art dit pourquoi aurait-elle
besoin de hardiesse et parce qu'elle
s'engage sur des terrains dangereux
on dirait qu'elle est poussé par un
fluide un pouvoir magnétique et ça nous
étonne pas nullement qu'armand aussi et
il m'arrive de me tromper d'époque et de
surprendre une conversation entre des
êtres qui sont morts depuis très
longtemps un jour à londres
j'étais seul dans un jardin et vous
savez qui j'ai entendu charles dickens
il parlait de libertis et de la petite
mail sa femme l'a trompée à chaque
instant pour lui rappeler que ces
enfants étaient malades et dickens
continue à parler de l'ouverture et de
la petite neil au charles charles disait
la pauvre femme tout en larmes
vous n'aimez pas vos enfants vous vous
étiez égaré dans un repli du temps mais
comment êtes vous sûr que ce n'est pas
par une illusion de la mémoire parce que
j'ai entendu des choses que personne ne
savait à cette époque on les a prises
plus tard quand on a publié le journal
intime de charles dickens et celui de sa
femme
vous avez raconté cette histoire à
s'élever oui et là elle cette phrase
merveilleuse
est-ce que vous avez mal quand vous
revenez ce qui prouve qu'elle avait
compris et vous avez répondu que j'étais
simplement un peu étourdi qu'on apprend
un voyage en avion
on part au petit fou on arrive dans un
pays
et c'est encore la nuit et vous croyez
que si lui voudrait aussi se perdre dans
une autre époque où même dans un autre
univers
s'il est naturel comment nous à attendre
de notre civilisation
rien rien qui rendent heureux alors il
faut s'évader je m'évade et leur vie
parce qu'il faut j'aimerais que ma
petite sylvie fasse aussi de ces petits
voyages petit voyage petit voyage dans
quoi dans l'espace intérieur dans le
temps éternel
appelez ça comme vous voudrez docteur le
nom ne fait rien à la chose
l'essentiel est de partir je vous
demande pardon mademoiselle mais quand
vous parlez de sylvie vous dites
toujours ma petite fille
oui oui je sais je sais n'est pas à moi
mais ce qui est à vous c'est votre
responsabilité dans ce qui arrive dans
ce qui est en train d'arriver
mais je les accepte docteur je l accepte
qu est ce qui est en train d'arriver
justement mademoiselle je ne le sais pas
votre petite fille lui le sait mais elle
ne veut pas le dire mais vous docteur
tous les livres que vous avez lu les
enfants que vous avez étudié aucun comme
ceci je m'étais toujours dit que s'il
m'arrivait de rencontrer une histoire
pareille je la regarderai en face et
bien
je n'ose plus
adèle de nouveaux débouchés bougies ben
pourquoi faire des bougies la nuit les
compères de quoi j'ai lu a peur d'aller
mois quatre bougies
drôle d'idée jamais de coupure la nuit
philippe comme je vais vite la paire
disparaître presque tout de suite
maintenant j'ai la solution regarde
[Musique]
c'est formidable attends je vais essayer
mais non pas comme ça
moi aussi j'y arrive pas molle bon
maintenant je suis à commencer circuit
d'après misère ça devrait marcher au
moins jusqu'aux nuages
ouais pas d'erreur c'est le début qui
m'embête cela nous faire je bon maître
attaque
[Musique]
s'avérer l'homme à ida si sûr est-ce que
je dérange mes petits amis non de terre
mais cherchons toujours bien jamais de
repos comme les grands savants
alors rené haas avril à 20 ex quasi d'or
est menacée ça c'est un piège
vous comprenez non je ne comprends pas
le sens des mots mais je comprends leur
attention
c'est mon appartiennent au langage
verticale
non c'est justement cela qu'on cherche à
éviter d'y avoir un moyen pour partir
tout droit
alors ils ont taqwa à vous les faire un
petit tour et puis revenir
oui c'est bizarre mais vous croyez qu'on
y arrivera pourquoi pas seulement les
lignes du trajet sont drôlement tordu
elles ne sont pas targuer elles sont
jolies jolies mais elles font des ans le
bizarre un peu le monde les miennes
ressemble aux lignes du réseau
est ce c'est vrai j'y avais pas pensé
mais vous avez raison de chercher
il faut mettre le connu et l'inconnu
côte à côte pour que le cas du
rajeunissent et pour que l'inconnu se
rapproche alors moi ça me fait plutôt
penser à mes collègues on à quai on
avance on va perdre pied on avance on a
pu pied note jean âgé ou malade je mets
des cailloux son parcours pour prendre
et puis pourquoi marché n'importe où
mais une fois au coquillage faut des
collectes obliger les bougies bon ça
c'est vers la fin juste avant même de
faire l'anneau le faire on passe à
travers et ni vu ni connu
ni vu ni connu on verra que du feu
les bougies allumées nous ferons signer
puis bonsoir eh bien les chers petits je
vous remercie
grâce à vous j'ai beaucoup appris des
choses très intéressantes points
je vais réfléchir là dessus un peu de
même je vous demande une seule petite
chose quand vous sentirez que vous allez
être obligés de décoller appelez-moi pas
trop tard
juste avant que rien aux parents bien
sûr que non je vous laisse
assurez-vous chère madame je viens de
les voir avec sa mèche paisiblement mais
en plus ces circuits incompréhensible
c'est ces cailloux ses bougies
rappelez-vous la marelle le labyrinthe
c'est une marelle laquelle on peut jouer
dans une chambre sur un tapis
les enfants aiment tant inventer des
jeux je ne comprends plus mes enfants je
sens que je les perds docteur je suis
tout de même leur mère je comprends et
je vous promets que ce soir ou demain ou
plus tard j'aurais trouvé le moyen de
les ramener à la réalité gdh appel il
faut que j'aille chez les coiffeurs que
je passe schéma couturière je peux y
aller il n'y a rien à craindre
faites ce que vous avez à faire je ne
quitte pas la tête merci docteur j'ai
fait avec tous il ya des zones quelque
chose et non je signe cet avant-midi
d'affaires du téléphone et du stade je
ne pense plus qu'à ça je téléphonerai de
chez le coiffeur pour savoir si tout
s'est bien passé par les enfants ça va
ils ont l'air bien dr annette les amis
je prends la moitié tout à l'heure
n'oublie pas de me téléphoner
[Musique]
jean dieu comment la route aujourd'hui
parfaitement déblayer madame le chasse
neige j'ai pensé très bien
[Musique]
j'espère je ne sais pas pourquoi j'ai 6
oh
moment
je suis là je n'ai pas fait plus rigide
hors effet cette voie on dit on et luigi
celli oui allez je vais tout de suite
mais qu'est ce qui est bien mon enfant
ma petite fille pas qu'est ce que tu
veux me voulait trouver tout est prêt
peut partir c'est merveilleux tu verras
mais c'est sûr que je reviendrai tout à
fait sûr
regarde moi je m'absente je fais mon
petit tout et je reviens juste un peu de
pertes ij toutes les 10 alors tu avais
[Musique]
elle vient syrie c'est là
allez
pourquoi
[Musique]
philippe c'est lui où êtes vous ne vous
cachez par dites moi vous êtes des
enfants
[Musique]
à ces bouts de terre mais qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire maintenant est ce
qu'ils sont mais à partir de maintenant
je n'en sais pas plus pour j'avais fait
promettre à philippe de m'appeler quand
il sentirait le moment venu calmement et
bien de disparaître
je ne pensais pas que j'y arriverai je
n'avais d'ailleurs aucun moyens à
disposition pour les aides reçues est
arrivé à quoi ils nous ont quittés parce
qu'on les a appelés
et parce qu'ils sont voulus ou qui tue
mes enfants ou êtes vous répondez moi
mes petits
et
[Musique]